那能干成这事儿的话，
这事儿也是违法的，
我和我前夫因该是六年前就扯开了，
分开认的没多久，
又还是相当于就是还是在一起了嘛，
那面也不知道我们分开了的，
我们有一个儿子，
一个女儿已经成年了，
知道我今年我53岁，
分开的原因的话是没有原则性的问题是他起初分开的获得的语言嘛，
就当时就逼我和他分开的话，
分开的时候我们资产是分清楚了的，
也受不了了嘛，
受不了的话，
我的资产分配上面的话是吃亏了，
应该只有他的1/5吧，
我的那个资产的话，
收益还可以，
可以租出去嘛，
有一些可以收些租金，
因为这期间的话，
因为我们没有离家了，
年龄也大了，
对外也是这个家庭，
所以说这几年的收益的话，
我全部都借给他了，
借给他大概有六七百个吧，
现在的话有原格性的问题要分开，
但是他一分钱也还不了我6000的话，
我就尽量把我的损求降低一些嘛，
那用错方式，
他的资产来比债啊，
他当时分的时候分4/5的资产，
现在4/5的这个资产价值多少啊？
嗯，
价值的话，
因为他这个有证的话，
大概有2000多的，
群里没证的话倒是还挺多，
关键是我现在主要是场地，
还有一个农。
真的有一个也在景区里面嘛，
有一套制定板，
当时是经过政府给意修建的，
那个手续有五六百个平方，
我想要这套房子，
想怎样合法的弄到我的手里面来，
觉得这个事儿啊，
还是要稳妥一点，
你就要他那个有证的，
2000多个平方的值多少钱，
有证的上面他就加盖了很多没有证的，
所以说卖也卖不出去啊，
这不了经济价值的那个，
但可以租嘛，
嗯，
是也不好租，
我们是个体工商户嘛，
这里的名称是单位名称，
反正是他因，
因为如果你要他那个没有证的在景区的那个东西啊，
不是涉及到你们两口子之间的问题，
他涉及到问题很多未知数，
你可能就算两口子之间我答应给你了，
到时候你也未必能够，
比如说要拆迁，
要干嘛，
你也未必能够拿到那一块的利益，
这些事儿啊，
我也不敢在直播间说，
实际上在，
尤其是在我们对吧，
在那种当地，
尤其是有景区的地方，
那说句难听点的话，
那些有权力的人翻手为云覆手为雨多了去了，
对不对，
嗯，
对对对对，
所以说我到当时我就说我不要在我的名下，
就是让他弄到儿子和女儿的名下，
现在也不同意，
名意上的话又不同意，
所以说我就看走法律程序，
还是把要怎么样走的更好一些，
如果有法律程序的话。
第一呢，
你们现在是嗯，
就不是夫妻的状态，
你们现在就是属于呃干什么，
属于平等的两个，
平等的两个老百姓，
然后你把钱给他，
他就应该给你打欠条是吧，
你把上我不他不应该给你打欠条，
他现在还不上你的钱，
你就可以去起诉他，
你起诉他就可以去冻结他名下的所有的资产，
他名下的资产定是有证的才算是他名下的资产，
没有证儿的就不算他名下的资产，
所以你要冻结的话，
你也只能冻结那个有证的两百千多平米的那个东西，
所因为他上面有加盖可能没证的，
所以说以我就是怕那个不好，
就事是这样子啊，
就算他加盖了，
上面加盖了一些没着的，
但是这个下面有这个2000多平米，
它是在法律上去做保护的，
对不对，
你大不了就是说我恢复原样，
我恢复到没加盖的状态，
那么我下面这2000多平米我是可以卖的呀，
我是可以过户的呀，
对，
儿子已经大了嘛，
如果是他是协议好，
还是走法律程序也好一些，
协议如果人家愿意给你的话，
当然是走协议了，
对不对，
这是最好的，
人家是不愿意给你，
那你只能是先去。
起诉他，
并且要那个查封他的2000多平米的建筑了，
对，
我女儿也是这个专科毕业的嘛，
她今年才才过法考嘛，
所以说如果说我她今天也不职，
所以说我说有什么需要女儿跟你帮顺的，
我女儿可以和你说几句吗？
可以呀，
没问题呀，
OK,
你哈啊，
就是那个协议的时候，
其实我父经常有证的话，
只有六七百的，
他是同意六七百的，
然后转到我哥哥的名下，
然后呃，
这个景区的房子他是同意转在我的名下，
但是是因为不知道怎么办这个景区的，
所以说才来问一下您还是说因为我妈妈她觉得如果这些方法都不稳妥的话，
是不是还是走法律程序更加的稳妥，
得看那个2000多平米的那个建筑价值多少钱，
因为你妈妈和你爸爸之间这个债权债务关系是五六百万到700万的债权债务关系，
如果人家2000㎡那个建筑物都已经抵掉这六百万七百万了，
你还打什么官司呢，
是不是因为2000多他协议的话，
我父亲我知道他肯定是不会同意的，
因为打官司的话，
拖的时间又会很长嘛，
然后也会比较不好看。
款哦，
然后还有一个车子，
就是当时那个车，
它的价值100多一点，
当时也是我妈妈他付的钱，
但是写在我爸爸的名下的，
然后想看一下这个车子是怎么才能比较好，
不通过我父亲可以直接的转回我母亲的名下吗？
不学法律的啊，
姑娘，
这个能记在你爸爸名下的车子，
怎么可能不经他同意就能转到你妈妈名下呢？
嗯，
那看来是不行，
然后就是随口一问啊，
不行的话，
这个是不行的啊，
就算能能，
就算能干成这事的话，
这事也是违法的，
对吧？
假方找个人跟你爸长挺像，
然后去办这个婚户手续是违法的，
你不能这么干啊，
我觉得是这样子的啊，
就是因为呃，
你爸爸和你妈妈之间，
他没有那个合法的夫妻关系，
所以呢，
而且你爸爸也跟你妈妈签了那个欠条，
这个是肯定是先协商嘛，
他如果协商能够把那个2000多平米的建筑过户到你哥哥名下，
嗯，
那就已经很好了，
2000多平米他怎么着也价值给六七百万了吧，
这么算的话，
不管在哪对不对，
不是卖的出现产生不了经济价值不呗，
其他还有没有更好的方法了吧，
是吧。
嗯，
没有什么更好的方法，
尤其是你景区那个东西啊，
景区那个建筑他没有办下来证儿，
没有办下来证儿是很难说过户到谁的名下，
在法律上给予保护的，
很难做到的，
如果说歧诉的话，
法院也不会用这个房子来抵债是吧，
那只先用有证的案例办，
是这样子，
没有证的东西，
法院如果用这种方式拿来抵债的话，
就相当于法院用判决的形式给了这个建筑物的一个合法身份的，
但这个建筑物是没有合法身份的，
但是我会用判决的方式给他一个合法身份的啊，
啊其他的就可以了，
好，
谢谢谢谢，
不见啊，
再见啊。
嗯，
我跟大家讲一下，
一般像这种没有证儿的，
就是没有房产证的这样一个建筑的话，
你想要通过法院把这个东西判给归谁所有的，
法院不会这么搞，
这么搞的话，
相当于大家都会去将这个漏洞，
所有没有证的建筑，
他们都可以通过，
比如说打离婚官司，
或者是打什么产权纠纷官司，
要求法院去把这个东西判给谁，
那就相当于法院扮演了一个角色，
相当于是呃，
本来这个是一个违章的，
或者说呃，
没有证的这样一个建筑，
法院就扮演了一个角色，
就赋予了他的一个所有权嘛，
这法院肯定不会这么干的，
这其一其二的话，
打设这是夫妻俩。
共同买了一个小产权房，
或者是干嘛干嘛的，
没有房产证对不对？
那在这种情况下，
法院有可能判归哪一个人使用，
不会判说这个东西归谁，
所有权归谁，
可能大家有很多人不太能理解，
第二就是所有权归谁的话，
他的权利就更大嘛，
对不对啊，
为谁使用，
你就只能用，
你也不能卖，
你也不能干嘛干嘛抵押，
你也不能干，
别的就只能给你用，
就这意思啊。